هي القصف الروسيه على دنيتك توقف خبر صار
طبعا للجميع فالحروب تؤلم الشعوب وان
اختارها القاده ربما يكون الامر مرتبط
بهدنه اعلنت روسي عنها لمده يوم ونصف
اعتبارا من منتصف نهار السادس من يناير
وحتى بدايه يوم الثامن من يناير اوكرانيا
في المقابل يبدو ان هذا دخلت في عناد مع
روسيا فوصفت هذه الهدنه بالنفاق وقالت ان
اي هدنه محتمله يجب ان تتضمن انسحاب
الروسيا من اراضيها اذا نحن امام تهدئه او
تصعيد لا ثالث لهما وامام التهدئه يظهر
الاطراف انقره تريد التوسط من اجل الحل
وهنا امسك اردوغان بهاتفه واجر مكالمتين
الاولى مع بوتين الذي ابدل افتتاحا لكن
اشترطه هو الاخر كما فعل اوكرانيا اشترط
قبولك للحقائق الاقليميه الجديده في مدع
اردوغان الى وقت اطلاق النار بشكل احادي
الجارح يبدو الامر تحقق ولو قليلا بوقفه
المكالمات الثانيه كانت مع الطرف الثاني
حيث ابلغه سعيه للتواصل لسلام دائما بين
روسيا واوكرانيا
مصابا اجريت مكالمه هاتفيه مع بوتين هذا
الصباح وناقشنا الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
بالتفصيل وتحدثنا ايضا عن ما يمكننا
القيام به في منطقتنا وقمنا بتقيم
العلاقات التركيه الروسيه ساجر مكالمه
هاتفيه مع الرئيس جريسكي بعد فتره وجيزه
وسنناقشون نتائج المباحثات التي اجريناها
مع الرئيس بوتين وكيف يمكننا تسهيل عمليه
السلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا وتعزيز
اتفاقيات ممر الحبوب وقضايا الامونيا
والاسمده الروسيه
ردا على سؤال عن اقتراح موسكو بشان الهدنه
قال رئيس الامريكي جو فايدن ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يحاول تنفس الصعداء
بوقف اطلاق النار لمده 36 ساعه
لكن التطورات الميدانيه تبدو عكس كل
محاولات التهدئه التي ذكرناها استعصاء
دخول الروسي لمدينه باخمت دفع موسكو الى
تغيير الخطه باب المدينه ضلت مصابه في وجه
الدبابات الروسيه رغم الكثير من المحاولات
على امتداد سته اشهر المسؤولون الروس
انفسهم كانوا اقروا بصعوبه المهمه في بخمت
من بينهم
القائد قائد مجموعه التي تقاتل هناك كما
ذكرنا امس فما هي الخطباء لموسكو بعد هذا
الانسحاب من بحر
صحيفه وسط الجورنال تحدثت عن تخلي روسيا
مرحله عن فكره الاستيلاء على باخمه وقالت
الصحيفه ان روسيا حولت مواقع المدافع
والدبابات من بخمه الى سوليدار من اجل
محاوله اختراق الجبهه من هناك ويكتسي محور
باخمط سوليدار اهميه خاصه بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه بعدما بات البوابه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه الوحيده للتقدم في عمق منطقه
مقاطعه دونيتك وتشكل الضخم وتواصل دار جزء
من الجبهه نفسها وتفصل بينهما مسافه 14
كلم فقط
وستتحاول القوه الروسيه توسيعه فوق
العسكري الذي فرضته على بخمه ليشمل رسول
الله
اسهل نسبيا في ظل تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه
في باخم والتحصين الجيد هناك